i anda nada boa tarde a todos
antes mais agradecer o convite e
agradecerá tabu espetacular que está a
ser claramente para a organização
eu venho aqui falaram que nem sobre mim
sobre o trajeto força com histórias e
agora vai esperar contar a minha
história e espero que seja interessante
saber para quem sonha eu venho tentar
explicar como é que através da raça
dedicação e da paixão conseguir cumprir
alguns sonhos atingiram os objetivos e
trabalha com um pouco porque a parte
mais encanta
espero que a maioria acha mais
interessante da minha apresentação
uma pergunta é por quê perguntou várias
vezes chega não ter que chega terço raça
dedicação e paixão
se cumprir os seus objetivos e realizar
alguns sonhos assim acredito que o meu
trabalho meu esforço
a pressa é uma coisa impossível é tentar
achar um dragão sozinho é impossível mas
pode não ser bem sucedido e muitos
muitas pessoas podem achar que não sou
bem sucedido do que aquela pessoa acha
que é ser bem sucedido
para mim ser vice versa guiné está aqui
de ser convidado para vir aqui falar com
vocês é pra mim uma razão em sentir bem
sucedido que não existem aqui o bruno de
souza que vocês não conhecem e que bruno
souza que vocês não conhecem alguém que
já conhecem
não não não é diferente da maioria das
pessoas
eu tive uma infância normal na minha
consciência
tive que trabalhar
os estilos estudos turim sempre o zé
teve que ajudar meus pais e funcionem na
construção civil
tive alguns anos da construção civil
depois decidimos lá e fui para uma
câmera fabricando nada a ver com o que
eu faço agora porque agora há 13 anos
pra cá eu acho que fui morar para o gol
e respondeu município
um técnico em informática e aí alguém
que fizesse um só eles como escola de
formação da escola informação hoje é
líder na sua área fatura 2 milhões de
anos eu acho que todos temos em
marketing porque foi dava essa
oportunidade de cheiro da própria
empresa eu tive como dizer se começará
com um técnico em informática mas ao
longo dos anos fui crescendo e sempre
fui respeitado as oportunidades que lhe
foram dadas
o photoshop é um homem não deixa de ser
um homem porque o galinheiro com um
asteróide para várias agências no mundo
mas não deixa de ser um homem bom
trabalho e eu tenho que respeitar o
trabalho que eu tenho diariamente assim
10.18 photoshop trouxe algum
conhecimento por isso estou aqui hoje
também porque está muito ligado ao topo
do porto em 2005 eu quero ter mais
iniciativa da secretaria de estado da
juventude no nem da iniciativa jovens
criadores
na categoria design gráfico mesmo tendo
curso tendo tempo teve um dos cinco
vencedores dessa categoria
toda a mostra e mostra tinha todas as
áreas e eu era o único não essencial
não foi isso que me impediu de ser um
dos chefes do conhecimento que eu
valorizo muito ferro foi obviamente mas
há outro tipo de reconhecimento e assim
deixa mais feliz e eu trouxe aqui um
caso que espero que seja um exemplo para
todos
eu não sei se todos conseguem espero que
sim
esta mensagem é de uma mãe
de um trabalho profissional ser muito
grande para fazer trabalhos no meio joga
no dragão forte do futuro porto e andava
muito em baixo segundo os pais e queria
desistir e um jogo normal ea outra não
criei esperava muito de maio de um
trabalho feliz comigo estavam muitos dos
trabalhos de bruno de souza e depois no
final ela envia o trabalho outros
precisam de privacidade mas receberam a
mensagem destas enquanto fazia coisas
pelo teu clube
nós não tem contudo dizer talento fazer
as coisas erradas no estácio
estamos a fazer as coisas certas apesar
disso tudo porque se não fosse assim não
não temos este resultado o uars e terem
falado que eu sou um dos melhores do
mundo deve ser a este site
infelizmente há pouco tempo deixou de
existir como marca porque foi comprado
por uma empresa de design europa que ao
comprar o ovo é absorvível e deixou de
existir
o ouro no afã de eu consegui aquecer
como artista como photoshop como chamar
eu quiser nos design não sabe precisar
nós ficamos chateados por sinalizar uma
só que não têm curso e eu não sou
designer mary design windows e só pensar
no portátil e seu design trabalhar copel
que olhando fixo gava não tem mesa não
tem não tem nada mas fui aprendendo e
foi aqui neste site
quando eu através de desafios diários
que os colocavam através da palavra
chave ou temas como colocar animais em
armaduras o pixies ou sei lá eu vou
contar aqui esta história do meio que
acho que elas a de santo por exemplo
ficaram com o desafio nos colocavam de
alimento
o trabalho do maior queda nos pedidos
que contássemos uma mentira uma mentira
grande né que não fizesse muito sentido
então essa história era eu todos os dias
vou passear no infante tem muitos
problemas porque tem medo do cão do meu
sim
esta é a história o trabalho ficou em
primeiro lugar como vários ficaram em
primeiro lugar mas é que explicar que ao
fazer esses trabalhos
é um dia bastante se quiser aplicar um
cunhado efeitos quer fazer alguma coisa
tinha que procurar o ataque não times
idosa e não tenho nada contra os
costumes obviamente é seria estúpido até
ter um ano na área imagem de respeito no
design
a única coisa que eu não goste do
trabalho com com design os dirigentes
anos é é um optar em pura
muitos judeus não saírem da caixinha
sexista a china mas não sei na caixinha
vêm muito formatados com um de nós faz
assim estamos fazendo essa sim
compreender esta fonte nosso lei aquilo
que sabe fazer o trabalho interno de
trabalho não corre e e causa causa
problemas
a única coisa conta ir embora claramente
respeito o o os cursos superiores
eu não não tem não tem nenhuma nenhum
problema em dizer que não tem felizmente
tem tido um percurso não preciso ter
esta oportunidade de futebol do porto
que é o que interessa
a minha relação com o clube não é
diferente da maior parte é para
profissional de apontar o caminho mas o
amor né porque é o foco do porto esteve
sempre presente na minha vida desde que
me lembro que sou portista enquanto vive
no porto
agora vive em lisboa não tenha essa
oportunidade mas sempre foi os jogos
quer o estádio das antas no estádio do
dragão e encontrar uma forma de apoiar o
porto que foi aplicada nas imagens com
esportistas fingimentos trote como devem
calcular foi criando foi tendo alguma
notoriedade e no meio desse trabalho
o motor em que surgiu um casaco alguns
de vocês devem conhecer e eu vou
explicar o que eu tenho é que fez uma
fotomontagem do cimo do porto
não não ruir num casaco pois nessa época
no estado
a fazenda já que o teste achei que não
ia fazer o que está na internet e isso é
muita reflexão e os limiares até é
exagerar milhares de comentários
é perguntar sobre a sacristia já está
produzindo conta custava atenções do
símbolo que desenvolvi no filme através
não sei quanto é curta e quero 10 e vou
ser muito sincero isso algumas pessoas
mais próximas de mim me conhece sabe
dessa minha opinião eu não goste muito
casar foi tanto assinado tão pressionado
para 14 mas é o porto e voltar do amor
que uma adepta ao clube
é difícil explicar basta ter o segundo
português olli reh disse que quem gosta
fica em oxi e isso é o flash diz não tem
como ser diferente e eu que eu fiz pelo
caminho
fui tentar saber quanto é que custava
fazer uma coisa destas
como é que o clube estava disposto a
ajudar
se é que estava na altura e respeito
também aos meus filhos meus amigos de
amy é muito caro é muito caro mandar
fazer é muito caro licenciar o foco do
porto algumas exigências muito
específicas para licenciar um produto eo
projeto foi ficando ficando na gaveta é
caro e e nunca foi minha e nunca ninguém
nunca fiz este casaco para ganhar
dinheiro alerta nunca foi um objetivo
ganhar dinheiro com o topo do porto eo
dinheiro das muitas vezes é um erro não
tem muita moral dinheiro não é o
dinheiro move nunca foi é mais a
realização pessoal e eu faço pelo porto
não é diferente do qual quer o nosso
fácil porque o que ama
isso fez com que a volta do bruno souza
e futebol clube do porto em 2014
o porto canal convida para fazer uma
reportagem
precisamente por causa dos trabalhos e
do amor que tenho ao topo do pódio da
prova com facundo formado por que a
única coisa que não gosta e não gosta
que no evento
é mas podem provar que são regras e
regulações r convidaram para fazer uma
reportagem
infelizmente teve um feedback o
estrondoso é e foi isso que trouxe o
clube a mim o clube no momento em que
fizemos
a reportagem com uma parte foi gravada
em lisboa e outra foi gravada no porto
no jogo ganhamos o primeiro é e neste
dia o diretor da marca da sua porto vai
ter comigo e disse olha a troca já
iniciamos os trabalhos são bons quando a
reportagem passar comigo vamos falar
comigo porque a gente tem coisas para
fazer e acho que agora vai ser agora que
vou trabalhar porta malta vai ficar toda
maluca com este sonho está se tornando
realidade
a reportagem passou eu fui eu fui ter
com ele eu e estava até mais tempo para
explicar a emoção que é aberto como eu
que a emoção que é entrar pela porta 1
do estádio do dragão e não sei fazer um
jogo perdido dinheiro com o socorro da
união não espera subir o valor passará
possa aplicar da costa rosa né
não sabia o que esperar nossa opinião
entretanto chegou até a tomar que
acompanha o produto por outro colega
foi uma conversa num papo mas muito à
vontade
hoje temos uma relação mais próxima e
pois muito à vontade desses grupos de
trabalho um filho mas teme fazer umas
coisas e foi por três projetos
nenhum deus que eu posso falar aqui
estão em desenvolvimento
eu vou reservar um horário
enfim vou explicar por que tenho que é
um princípio na próxima época vai ter
mais velhos do dia mas estava a dar
coisa né eu vi fui foi nem novamente
mesmo não tem não tem não tenho mais
palavras porque foi concretizado tava
chegando a um ponto de realizar um sonho
a partir disto o ano passado não tem a
ver com esses três projetos o ano
passado o diretor da marca do fenômeno
fraudes bruno temos aqui um palmo uma
coisa que mel vai ter as portas já temos
uma outra vez mas não vai tirar os
portes e não posso ficar aqui o espírito
de tal convidar os artistas que
participaram nessa questão dos portos
porque não estava claro
fiz dois trabalhos e eu o chamei pra quê
para tentar explicar o com um ganho do
sucesso a que possa ter junto das
comunidades portuguesas
eu acho que eu tento passar muita emoção
de um adepto aos trabalhos escolares faz
com que as pessoas tenham uma grande
atividade ou mesmo pela raça ou aqui
a mística do pai com o filho e mais uma
vez fechando o feedback das pessoas
quanto tens nesse trabalho um pai e um
filho quando é um surf e enviam quantas
mil de clientes e mostrar raça mais uma
vez que sabe das coisas vai não foi com
um propósito é que não o ajudará o povo
estudasse bastante bastante feliz com
estes vieram também alguns algumas
coisas também que nunca imaginava foi o
contacto com os grosso e eu não tenho
não tenho perspectiva nem quero criar
uma agência de imagem para os gaúchos
já fui convidado por uma delas disse que
não queria mais uma vez respeitando a
possibilidade que eu tive no meu
trabalho atual
e olha que importa pelo porto como uma
coisa à parte 1 é o que eu quero é o
qualquer negócio contribuir mas sempre
com o devido respeito à minha vida
ajudou muito neste ano
o elton foi o primeiro pagar também o
elton não sou esperta quadra
convidando para ver um trabalho que eu
fiz deu convidam pra prazer assistir a
um jogo no camarote de uma parte nem
tornamos amigos já tem contribuído com
outros trabalhos é no clinic barreto que
eu faço todos os anos presenteamos os
miúdos ano passado com trabalhos meus
foi um sucesso felizmente depois me quer
casa e assim maio o lyon conta tomar até
bem pouco tempo para fazer uma imagem de
capa também provavelmente resultado de
uma reportagem da tv mexicana fizeram
sombra sobre os meus trabalhos e e quer
casar eles também recentemente pediu
para fazer uma capa para o facebook teve
uma uma coisa muito interessante que foi
agradecer e isso deu origem ao jogo por
exemplo fazer uma notícia sobre isso
o helton é uma figura isso convida para
almoçar foi buscar a casa da minha mãe
perfeita e eu tô em casa à espera já
passei para buscar welton vai indicar a
casa dos meus pais a prefeita que não
estão todos aqui mas é realizado
aconteceu e se existe visual força o
trabalho que tenho feito pelo topo do
porto
é um sonho realizado e puxa aqui é um
trabalho que disse que ia falar
um dos projetos que foi proposto no
momento que o o diretor da marca me
chamou para assinar o contrato
no quadro acima a passar aqui para
assinarmos o contrato do projeto x já
não é a mesma coisa já estou mais à
vontade ainda bem e tem um contrato e eu
disse para ela tudo bem no saque e houve
lesão iniesta tudo certo e que já estava
assinado pelo administrador da pt que é
o fernando gomes da sala
não vou assinar
eu trabalho só temos que ver onde está o
homem é o homem
presidente sim pode ser assinado pelo
administrador projeto não pode ser assim
você não tem noção daquilo que fizeste
não é o mesmo que o ficha
há uma ficha e eu fui assinar esse
contrato a sala do pentecostes a
secretária técnica um código tem que
entrar lamenta que o peixe só somos nem
apresente a foto que você vê no novo
governo
alvo da assinatura de pinto da costa
poder fazer isto é poder viver e com o
público com o fruto do meu trabalho nos
força a minha dedicação da minha raça
sabe o que entender não tem como eu não
achar que chega eu acho que chega desde
que seja bem aplicado
pode se dizer que são a voz curso mas
acreditam que os fósseis é isso aí
isso porque a vossa paixão só fazer
propaganda porque os sonhos falou é que
em sonhos de sonho comanda a vida
falando em enfim poemas e faz frases
feitas e é pra pessoas fernando e se eu
posso deixar aqui alguma ideia é se
sonha só é bastante
não tenha medo não tenho medo dos sonhos
saibam as geleiras expectativas
às vezes os sonhos são desfeitos nós
levamos muitas expectativas e faz quando
não acontece com cremes e nós aqui às
vezes cometemos alguns erros sejam
determinados mas não tomar nada como
garantido porque a vida muda de repente
eu também pensava que até os sons dos
prêmios de público
a vida muda mesmo tratamento para
estejam preparados para isso tenta ser
melhor se todos os dias tal como wolf
mostrou isso eu tive que ser melhor para
iniciar no mundo mundo de sites site
chegou a ter 25 minutos vencedor de
photoshop sony até fazer estudo sendo
feliz né sempre falei que o mais
importante era só isso que falta pouco
né